hello everyone welcome to another
episode of unlocking lily so it's always
been my dream to be a speaker which led
me to quit my day job to work in mentor
under Evan full-time and all of you are
coming along for this journey with me in
every episode I take on a different
challenge to help me grow as a speaker
so I just got back from giving my first
TEDx talk and a lot of you guys have
been asking me how did you get in and
look I get it maybe you want to be a
professional speaker maybe it's on your
bucket list or maybe you have an idea
that you want to share with the rest of
the world here's the good news
there are two to three thousand TEDx
events happening every year now the bad
news is that the process of applying to
becoming a speaker it's a little bit
complicated so in this video I'm gonna
make it easy for you and share the seven
steps in getting your first TEDx talk
step number one is the location you need
to determine how far you are willing to
travel so when you go on their website
Ted comm / TEDx / events you are going
to see all the TEDx events happening
around the world
so for me I looked at all the TEDx
events that were within a six hour drive
from Toronto so you really want to think
about how far are you willing to travel
because you could have a TEDx event
happening in your backyard but it's not
happening for another year or you might
get rejected so the farther you're
willing to travel the better your
chances are in getting in
step number two is the timing you want
to only look at the TEDx events are
happening at least three months from
today the TEDx organizers want to make
sure that they finalize all their
speakers three months prior to the event
so if you see something that is a month
from now you can still apply but chances
are they're already how their speakers
are chosen so to help you narrow down
your search you need to go back to the
theme website and you could filter it by
month and year step number three is the
theme every single TEDx event will have
their own theme so the TEDx event that I
spoke at their theme was act local think
global Ted is all about sharing ideas
and each TEDx event organizer is asked
to come up with their own theme because
they want to generate a global
conversation around that specific topic
so to maximize your chances of getting
in you need to make sure that your idea
aligns up with their theme as closely as
possible unfortunately there is no easy
way of finding out their theme from the
main website you would have to go on the
individual website of each TEDx event so
for example if you want to apply to TEDx
Toronto you need to Google TEDx Toronto
and once you're on their website you
will see that their theme is legacy now
knowing that you could do one of two
things you could either tweet your idea
to mash a theme of legacy or if it's too
far outside of what you want to talk
about you cannot have fun and just move
on to the next TEDx event now this is
the most crucial part this is the reason
why most people don't get in because
their idea does not match the theme
step number four is the application this
is your chance to introduce yourself and
your idea to the organizers now they're
going to ask you to either fill out an
online form or to email them directly
they're going to ask you general
questions like your name your phone
number and your email address but that's
the easy stuff the most important part
is your idea
so when submitting your idea you want to
focus on these three things number one
is what is your one idea that you want
to share you may have multiple amazing
ideas but you want to make sure that you
bring it down to one easy to understand
idea so for example my one idea was
finding your one word number two is how
does your idea relate to their theme the
TEDx organizers want to see that you
genuinely care and you took the time to
research a theme and that you are the
right fit for their event so for example
the TEDx event that I spoke at their
theme was at local think global
so I presented my idea that finding your
one word is knowing what you stand for
which is acting locally and now knowing
your one word you could go out and
change the world which is thinking
globally so you want to really make sure
you customize your idea and present it
in such a way that it matches their
theme because this is the reason why
most people don't get in because our
idea does not relate to their theme and
number three is why are you the
authority to speak on this topic TEDx
organizers want to bring in experts who
can speak from a place of experience and
knowledge what they don't want are
people who just have theories and have
nothing to back it up with you want to
make sure that you show that you're not
that person so for me I spoke about your
one word I
have done interviews on it I have done
coaching on it I even have a close
relationship with the author who
developed the idea I am the authority to
speak on this topic now here's a tricky
part you have to explain all of that in
a hundred to 300 words so you have to
make sure that you make every single
word count now I would suggest that you
dedicate a hundred words to that one
idea that you want to share a hundred
words so how does it relate to the theme
and a hundred words do why are you the
authority to speak on this topic they
may also ask you for a bio and links to
your previous speaking engagements so
for me I didn't have any previous
experiences so what I did was I
forwarded some links to the YouTube
videos that I made so if you're like me
and you don't have any previous
experience you could start making some
YouTube videos upload it on to your
channel and submit that as your example
step number five is the interview
so congratulations they like what they
saw in the application and they want to
get to know you and your idea better
they are going to schedule a 30-minute
Skype call with you and their top
organizers and I know it's a both really
exciting and really nerve-wracking at
the same time because you have no idea
what they are going to ask you which is
why I'm here I've been through this
process and I'm gonna help you through
this the reason why they want to talk to
you is that they want to be certain that
you are the right fit for the event and
that you can actually speak and not just
write really well here are some typical
questions that they are going to ask you
number one is what is that idea that you
want to share the reason why they want
to know because they are can treat by
the small description that you wrote in
the application they want to get to know
it further to make sure that it is a
right fit for the event so you need to
make sure that you practice articulating
your idea before the call number two is
how does your idea relate to their theme
you need to show that you have done your
homework and you know exactly how your
idea matches their theme and again you
need to practice answering that question
because it's gonna come up for sure
number three is why do you deserve to be
on that stage they may have 500 to
thousand applicants what makes you so
special to go on that stage this is
where you need to sell yourself and your
idea to win over those organizers you
need to show that you're unique and your
ideas unique you can start by sharing
how your idea has helped you the people
around you and now it's time to share
with the world
number four is what is the final
takeaway for the audience Ted is about
sharing ideas but they are also about
taking action so you need to think about
what do you want the audience to do
after they have listened to your talk
and number five is are you available for
two days TEDx events will have a dress
rehearsal day which is where you could
try a PowerPoint presentation make sure
it works properly they will try the
lighting on you and most importantly you
can practice your speech on that big
stage and the next day is the big day
it's where you can step on that stage
and share your idea with the whole world
so you need to make sure that you are
available for two full days for the
event
step number six is the one pager so
awesome job during the interview you
have impressed the organizers that you
spoke with us however every TEDx event
will have multiple organizers so the
next step is the organizers are you
spoke with are going to take your one
pager and present it to the rest of the
committee so now what's on your one
pager your one pager is basically an
expansion of your application so number
one is what is the idea that you want to
share and as a bonus you could add in
the audience takeaway number two is how
does your idea relate to the theme
number three is why are you the
authority to speak on this topic once
again I would recommend you dedicate 1/3
of the page to the idea you want to
share along with the audience take away
a third of the patient related a theme
and a third of the page - why are you
the authority to speak on this topic now
this is the final step before the
approval this is you make it or break it
chance and you are not going to be there
in person to defend your idea so you
need to make sure that your one pager is
compelling enough to win over the rest
of the committee and you also need to
make sure that your one pager is easy to
understand so I would suggest you show
you one pager to a couple of friends
that have no idea what you're talking
about and see how they react after
reading your one pager if they still
don't know what you're talking about you
need to go back and tweak your one pager
but if they do understand what you're
talking about then your one pager is
ready and you could go ahead and submit
it
and finally step number seven is the
approval and preparation first of all
congratulations you are in and you need
to do the happy dance but we focus right
there yes you are going to be a TEDx
speaker and you want to take in a moment
to really feel the honor to be on a TEDx
stage and it's a wonderful community to
be a part of and now you got to do some
work okay so within the first couple of
days of approval you are going to
receive a detailed timeline of all the
things that you need to do from the
organizers okay the first thing first
you need to submit a headshot in a bio
and that's due within the first week of
approval number two if you are planning
on using PowerPoint you need to make
sure that your slides are ready to be
submitted at least two weeks before the
event date and number three you need to
prepare a talk of your life this is your
opportunity to spread your idea with the
rest of the world so what I did was the
first month I wrote out my talk and I
tweaked it and I practiced it until I
was satisfied with something on paper
and the second month I practice
everywhere I practice in the park in
front of all these people I practice in
front of a busy restaurant I practice by
myself at home I practiced three to four
hours a day until I was comfortable and
once you're comfortable you want to get
the feedback of someone you trust
someone who would give you honest
constructive criticism and then you want
to take that feedback and apply it and
continue to practice practice practice
and practice until the final day and
there it is I just gave you the seven
steps in getting your first TEDx talk
now I made the steps really simple but
it's not going to be easy getting in
expect to get rejected many times the
point is to learn from the process every
time you get rejected we reach out to
that TEDx organizer and sincerely tell
them that this is your dream and what
can you do better for next time now be
prepared though they are all very busy
and they're probably not gonna get back
to you ever but you just never know okay
but it's worth their try because there
might be a TEDx organizer out there that
will help you it may also help for you
to reach out to someone who have spoken
at TEDx TEDx speakers know how hard it
is to get in and if you show that you
sincerely care they will be more than
happy to help you out
now all the steps and all the feedback
it's all great but it's not going to
work
unless you believe in yourself if you
want to be on that TEDx stage you need
to believe that you are a worthy your
idea is important and your talk will
change the world
because if you don't believe nobody else
will so for my next challenge I'm
traveling back to Michigan where I'll be
speaking at a congregation so after my
TEDx talk one of the audience members
came up to me and requested to see if I
would speak at our congregation and of
course I said yes
and that's the thing guys if you want to
be a speaker the more talks like you do
and the better you do with those talks
the more talks is gonna lead to so I'm
gonna be giving the exact same talk
which I'm pretty comfortable with and I
want to stretch my comfort zone a little
bit
actually a lot one of the things that
I'm really scared of is actually singing
in public so I'm going to do something
daring I'm gonna sing the intro to my
talk you guys need to wish me luck and I
will see you guys in Michigan and I have
a special shadow for Alexandra to fill
avec Alexandra thank you so much for
writing that really sweet comment on my
last episode and I know that you want to
be a TEDx speaker too so there it is I
gave
the seven steps and all you have to do
is apply and finally the question of the
day is what is that one idea that you
want to share with the rest of the world
write in the comments below and I'll be
sure to join in on the discussion thank
you so much for watching and more
importantly being on this journey with
me I'm seeing a lot of you guys right in
saying that my journey is inspiring you
to go out there and do the things that
you want to do and you have no idea how
happy that makes me so thank you so much
again it means the world to me and I'll
see you guys very very soon if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
so it would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details